Welcome to another episode of the show, everybody. It's kind of crazy watching the ticker on the episode count go up and up. I always forget how many of these we've done. It's too many now. We're excited to be here with Marcus. Marcus is the staff product manager for Atlas Search at MongoDB. Welcome to the show, Marcus. Thank you. Happy to be here. Though we were doing a little bit of pre-show recording, I know we kind of hinted that sometimes we already got pretty excited. Marcus was helping us understand search, something that personally I've already known is like Google, right?
大家好，欢迎收听本期节目。看着节目期数不断上升，感觉挺疯狂的。我总是忘记我们已经录了多少期。现在真的太多了。我们很高兴今天能请到马库斯（Marcus）。马库斯是MongoDB公司Atlas Search团队的资深产品经理。欢迎来到节目，马库斯。谢谢。很高兴来到这里。虽然我们在录制前稍微聊过，我也知道我们有时已经很兴奋了。马库斯当时在帮我们理解搜索，这对我个人来说一直觉得就像谷歌那样，对吧？
Search engine. But even though I've done database stuff before, my search always amounts to like equals equals checks and even getting those wrong because it turns out, yeah, anyways, it's difficult. So I'm excited to learn some stuff today and i'm glad marcus is here to help us through this but before we dig into that we always like to ask people kind of how you got into tech your story kind of like you know origin story marvel superhero whatever it wants to be it can be kind of boring it's all right but like marcus how'd you kind of like first get into tech? Was there like a moment you remember as like, this is the first time I got excited about computers or programming or? family's desktop computer just like opening it up like i got some tools waited till my mom was
搜索引擎。但尽管我以前做过数据库相关的工作，我的搜索通常还是只局限于“等于等于”这种精确匹配，而且往往还搞砸了，因为事实证明，唉，总之这很难。所以我很高兴今天能学到一些新东西，也很高兴马库斯能来帮助我们弄懂这些。但在我们深入探讨之前，我们总是喜欢问嘉宾是怎么进入科技领域的，你的故事，就像漫威超级英雄的起源故事一样，不管是什么都可以。故事有点无聊也没关系，不过马库斯，你是怎么最初接触到科技的？有没有哪个瞬间让你记忆犹新，觉得这是你第一次对计算机或编程感到兴奋？
gone from work at work and my dad was cooking and i started unscrewing like the panel it was a compact computer i remember like it was yesterday and like when my mom got back from work you know i knew i had the same corporal punishment coming to me that I had the first three times. And I wish I didn't mind, like it was worth it to look inside the computer each time and, you know, pull something random out. And, but this time my dad intervened and he was like, you know, maybe we should put them in this program. It was called DAPSEP. It was like Detroit area, like community education, something or like pre-engineering was the the the program. It was like extracurricular. Every Saturday you'd go up to the university was was just a mile from my house,
我家的台式电脑，我就是把它拆开。我拿了一些工具，等到我妈去上班、我爸在做饭的时候，我开始拧下机箱面板——那是一台康柏（Compaq）电脑，我记得就像昨天发生的一样。然后当我妈下班回家时，你知道的，我知道等待我的体罚和前三次一模一样。我真希望当时我不在乎，因为每次能看一眼电脑内部，随便抽出一件东西出来，（挨罚）都是值得的。但这次我爸介入了，他说：“也许我们应该让他参加这个项目。”那个项目叫DAPSEP。那是底特律地区（Detroit area）的一个社区教育项目，大概是类似预科工程的项目。是个课外活动。每个星期六，你都要去那所离我家只有一英里远的大学，
University of Detroit, and start learning about a range of topics in engineering, ranging from building circuits, like basic circuits, to programming computers on QBasic, using QBasic. So that was certainly my first time when I was like, okay, this isn't random. There's some logic to this. It's actually pretty cool. And one thing led to another. There was an extracurricular class. Well, my brother was studying computer engineering at first, and I would like look through his books with bewilderment and curiosity. Then my girlfriend, I mean, all we did was hold hands. We were 14. She like forced me to go to like web development with the calculus teacher in high
底特律大学（University of Detroit），开始学习一系列工程学的主题，从搭建电路，比如基础电路，到在QBasic上用QBasic编程计算机。所以那绝对是我第一次觉得，嗯，这可不是随机的。这里面是有逻辑的。实际上挺酷的。然后就一环扣一环。还有一个课外班。嗯，我哥哥最初在学计算机工程，我会带着困惑和好奇去翻看他的书。然后是我女朋友——其实我们当时也就是手拉手，我们才14岁——她非逼着我去参加高中时计算老师办的网页开发班。
school. So I went to his class and I was like, I mean, this stuff just clicked with me right away in college where I was really focused on some of the mostly other areas primarily because I was much weaker in these areas, like, uh, research and writing. I found myself researching about computers and like the FCC and radio. So then I, I started to work on mesh networks with my friends and like, they're powering like internet for protesters and some of the big protests in New York City. We're, you know, then trying to provide Internet to migrant communities in Brooklyn when we left school. And then like impoverished communities just around the country, it turns out super expensive to build your own internet infrastructure and the ad hoc internet infrastructure.
所以我去了他的课堂，然后我就觉得，这些东西在大学里一下子就吸引了我，当时我主要专注于其他一些领域，主要是因为我在这些领域的根基薄弱得多，比如研究和写作。我发现自己总是在研究计算机、FCC（联邦通信委员会）和无线电。所以后来，我和朋友们开始研究网状网络（mesh networks），它们在纽约市的一些大型抗议活动中为抗议者提供互联网支持。离开学校后，我们又试图为布鲁克林的移民社区提供互联网。然后还有全国各地贫困社区的互联网。事实证明，建立自己的互联网基础设施和临时互联网基础设施是非常昂贵的。
And it would be a challenge today. There's a lot of cultural inertia to go out and say, invest in the hardware and then invest in the maintenance burden of maintaining a node and a mesh network. I think one day that will be important in certain regions in the United States, particularly like rural regions.
而且在今天这也是一个挑战。要想走出去说“去投资硬件，然后去承担维护节点和网状网络的维护负担”，这背后存在着很大的文化惰性。我认为总有一天这在美国某些地区会变得很重要，特别像农村地区。
But there's many areas in the world where these sort of networks exist. But like going from the web development to the networking stack really sort of gave me a well-rounded foundation and like the Q basic. And then how I really started to learn was when I struck out on my own and started my own company focused on like security for home networks, like IOT, like when you plug in your router and then set up all the devices you got for Christmas, some of those devices were made smart very hastily and they would include, you know, self-signed certificates, for instance, default passwords or use weak encryption. And like, your network is only as strong as the weakest link. And I saw I saw a trend in 2015 2014, really, of people increasingly working from home and adding more of these devices to their networks. Like I would tell
但世界上有很多地区都存在这种网络。从网页开发转向网络协议栈，真正为我奠定了全面基础，还有QBasic。然后我真正开始自学的时候，是我自己单干并创办了一家公司，专注于家庭网络的安全性，比如物联网（IoT）。就像当你插上路由器，然后设置你圣诞节收到的所有设备时，其中一些设备是非常仓促地被做成智能设备的，它们会包含自签名证书、默认密码，或者使用薄弱的加密方式。而且，你的网络坚固程度取决于它最薄弱的环节。我发现——在2015年、2014年左右——人们越来越多地在家工作，并在网络中添加了更多这类设备。比如我会告诉
people like your drop cam, that's probably okay. But like the second, third tier IP camera, who knows? Were you helping people like walk them down by, you know, kind of just applying best practices or were you doing like pen testing against them, sort of figuring out, Hey, this third party thing has some backdoor or a little bit of both. Like I'm just trying to kind of position like the kind of work you were doing yeah so we were just providing like an ids ips system mostly focused on ids so like you'd actually buy hardware device and then we have a device that's sort of like a sandbox in between your router and your modem ids is intrusion detection system that's right okay that's right so you know
人们，像你的Dropcam（云摄像机）可能还行。但如果是第二、第三梯队的IP摄像头，谁知道呢？你是在通过应用最佳实践来帮助人们防范，还是在对它们进行渗透测试之类的，试图弄清楚“嘿，这个第三方设备有后门吗”？或者两者都有点？我只是想大致了解一下你当时在做什么。是的，所以我们只是提供一个IDS/IPS（入侵检测/防御）系统，主要专注于IDS。所以你实际上会购买一个硬件设备，然后我们有一个设备，有点像放在你路由器和调制解调器之间的一个沙盒。IDS就是入侵检测系统（Intrusion Detection System），对吧？没错。好的，所以你知道，
we drop a linux box an embedded linux system in promiscuous mode in your home and then you tell people that if you go to someone's house and say i'm going to put this promiscuous mode network card in your like i feel like they're going to think something and it's not the right thing. Well, like that's right. It's better to know who's in promiscuous mode on your network than to not know. Right. Because there may already be some devices, some promiscuous devices in there. And it was just like it was a super hard problem. I still don't know how big of a problem it is today, even with 100% of people working from home in these knowledge positions, knowledge jobs, you know, working from home in some capacity,
我们在你家里以混杂模式（promiscuous mode）投放了一个Linux盒子、一个嵌入式Linux系统。如果你去别人家里说“我要把这个混杂模式的网络卡插到你的……”，我感觉他们会胡思乱想，而且想的都不是好事。嗯，对的。知道谁在你的网络中处于混杂模式，总比不知道要好。对吧？因为里面可能已经有一些设备、一些处于混杂模式的设备了。这真是一个超级难的问题。直到今天，即使100%的人都在家办公，从事这些知识型岗位、知识型工作，在某种程度上都在家办公，我依然不知道这到底是一个多大的问题。
you know, like I think the home is remains an attack vector, but like that company was bought by another company kind of going after a mesh networking problem, which was funny. I was like, this is going to be really, really hard folks. And they're like, no, just focus on the security and observability stuff. And I'm like, fine, fine. But like, you know, I think that remains a hard problem. But as a part of that, as a part of that work for months, people were just, you know, we're just mostly out of the box threat signatures, some stuff we tune. It's very difficult to do this. We were collecting a ton of data and we had done some interesting things, this heterogeneous networks proved to be virtually impossible without a search engine.
你知道，我认为家庭仍然是一个攻击向量，但那家公司被另一家公司收购了，后者有点在追求网状网络的问题，这挺搞笑的。当时我说：“这会非常非常难的，各位。”而他们说：“不，只要专注于安全性和可观察性东西就行。”我说：“好吧，好吧。”但是，你知道，我认为那仍然是一个难题。但作为那项工作的一部分，在几个月的时间里，人们只是——我们主要使用开箱即用的威胁签名，还有一些是我们自己调整的。要做这件事非常困难。我们收集了大量数据，并且做了一些有趣的事情。事实证明，如果没有搜索引擎，这种异构网络几乎是不可能的。
Oh, OK. Well, hang on. There's a bit of a side topic. I want to say this thing you're saying, like the home network remains and like all these iot a threat and like i myself find like unsure how many is people hooked up directly to their isps modem like their iot device and that's what's getting hacked versus people with a sensible you know to have a router with some basic default firewall rules and that and like i don't know on balance what it is but i am shocked i did a little very little bit of security stuff in in college you know just some basic like sql injection some like payload stack overflow stuff just enough to kind of like okay i get it but there are people i work with who went to you know four-year degrees at big name schools
哦，好的。等等。这有点偏离主题了。我想说你刚才提到的话题，比如家庭网络依然存在威胁，所有的物联网都是威胁。而我发现自己不确定有多少人是直接把物联网设备连到ISP（互联网服务提供商）的调制解调器上的，从而导致被黑的；相比之下，有多少人拥有明智的做法——比如拥有一个带有一些基本默认防火墙规则的路由器。我不知道这两者的平衡点是什么，但我感到震惊的是，我在大学里做过一点点安全方面的事情，你知道，只是一些基本的SQL注入、一些栈溢出（payload stack overflow）之类的内容，刚好够让我觉得“好吧，我明白了”。但有些和我一起工作的人，他们毕业于名牌学校的四年制学位，
who are like they don't get it you say they're like oh yeah hackers are a thing but like like my home network's not a big deal. Like, that's not true. Like, you wouldn't actually encounter in the wild, like a stack overflow that doesn't just crash your computer. Like the belief that you can deliver a tailored payload automatically via like a worm or something, like they know it exists, but they don't think it'll happen to them. And so I'm like shocked how even people who should know better or even understand the mechanism how these work
却根本不懂。你跟他们说，他们会觉得：“哦，对，黑客是真实存在的，但我的家庭网络不是什么大不了的事。”这其实不对。你在现实中实际上不会遇到那种只是让你的计算机崩溃的栈溢出。那种“你可以通过蠕虫或类似的东西自动投递定制攻击载荷”的信念——他们知道它存在，但他们不认为这会发生在他身上。所以我感到很震惊，即使是那些本该更清楚、甚至理解这些工作机制的人，
and by the way have seen each other's code like they still don't believe that that's like an ongoing threat it's actually shocking to me yeah i mean that that's a great question i think that we as software engineers suffer from groupthink tremendously and confirmation bias is like if it compiled it must be good ship it you know what i mean and folks are moving fast it's a super competitive space there's a lot of capital flowing into software so there's a lot of people like doing it, right? Tasting that. And we have seen recently like the cryptocurrency industry is, well, it's great because it's like you can express money directly in code, whereas like typically it's an abstraction, right? It's like most ways programmers interface with money is a shallow copy. So like a shallow copy
顺便说一句，他们还看过彼此的代码——他们仍然不认为这是一个持续存在的威胁。这实际上让我感到震惊。是的，我的意思是，这是一个很好的问题。我认为我们作为软件工程师，饱受群体思维（groupthink）之苦，确认偏误（confirmation bias）也是如此——就像如果它能编译通过，那它一定很好，直接发布吧！你知道我的意思吗？大家都在快节奏地推进，这是一个竞争极其激烈的领域，有大量的资本涌入软件行业，所以有很多人在做这件事，对吧？品尝到了甜头。我们最近看到，比如加密货币行业，嗯，这很棒，因为你可以直接在代码中表达金钱，而通常这只是一种抽象，对吧？就像程序员与金钱交互的大多数方式都是浅拷贝（shallow copy）。所以，对那些不熟悉的人来说，浅拷贝
for those who aren't familiar with this, like it's a reference to something. It doesn't actually represent the thing that you're pointing to, right? Specifically in memory. But like in this case, shallow copy of money is like, okay, I'm using Shopify. I have a Shopify checkout button. That Shopify checkout button talks to Stripe. That Stripe API talks to First Data or some PayFact. And that PayFact talks to some mainframe stood up in like the 1960s. Who knows what that's running? Somewhere in Atlanta, probably. And with like the cryptocurrencies,
就是对某样东西的引用。它实际上并不代表你所指向的东西，对吧？具体在内存中。但在这种情况下，金钱的浅拷贝就像是：好吧，我正在使用Shopify。我有一个Shopify结算按钮。那个Shopify结算按钮与Stripe对话。那个Stripe API与First Data或某些PayFact对话。而那个PayFact与某个在20世纪60年代建立的大型机（mainframe）对话。谁知道那里运行的是什么？可能在亚特兰大的某个地方。而对于加密货币，
what I found so fascinating from a security standpoint is you can point to, and I just started learning Solidity early this year, like for the second time, this time it was a lot easier. Ethereum's programming language. Yeah, Solidity powers the EVM or allows you to interface with the EVM. That's right, Ethereum virtual machine. And like what I found so interesting and profound about it,
从安全的角度来看，我发现最迷人的是你可以指出——我今年年初开始学习Solidity，这是第二次，这次容易多了——以太坊的编程语言。是的，Solidity驱动着EVM，或者允许你与EVM进行交互。没错，以太坊虚拟机（Ethereum Virtual Machine）。我发现它如此有趣和深奥的地方在于，
and I'm assuming this is how it is in all of them. I don't, my knowledge is limited there, admittedly, is that you can point directly to value. It's like a deep copy that you're like, this money exists really in the world. It can be spent for like goods and services and that's in your code. And so the security mishaps, the mistakes that are inevitable to happen in our software impact people a lot faster. In the case of that, there's like some folks working on like these bridges between two chains. And that's a super risky endeavor that I'm staying away from all the way. And like people lose 400 million and it's gone right away. And people feel that they know it. They know it,
而且我假设所有这些都是这样的。我承认我的知识有限，那就是你可以直接指向价值。这就像是一个深拷贝（deep copy），你会觉得：这些钱在现实世界中真的存在。它可以用于购买商品和服务，并且它写在你的代码中。因此，安全失误——我们软件中不可避免会发生的错误——对人们的影响要快得多。在这种情况下，有些人正在致力于两条链之间的桥接（bridges）。这是一项超级冒险的尝试，我将彻底远离它。人们会损失4亿美元，并且瞬间就没了。人们感受到了这一点，他们知道了，
which is important to me for security. Because if you look at the target hack, you know, you might remember that big target fiasco 2014, maybe 2013, where the HVAC system, the customer, I mean, a contractor was debugging the HVAC system. Their home network was compromised. Their VPN credentials were compromised. Folks, a command and control server somewhere was able to then skim credit cards because they were on the same network as the HVAC system for whatever reason. I'm sure that person isn't employed by Target anymore. Not the HVAC person. They probably still are the person who put those in the same network. You know, like once the, once those credit card numbers were taken and those credit cards were used, there was a charge
这对我的安全工作来说很重要。因为如果你看看塔吉特（Target）黑客事件，你可能还记得2014年、也许是2013年那场巨大的塔吉特惨败：空调系统、客户——我是说，一个承包商在调试空调系统。他们的家庭网络被攻破了。他们的VPN凭证被泄露了。各位，某个地方的命令和控制服务器（command and control server）随后能够窃取信用卡，因为无论出于何种原因，它们与空调系统在同一个网络上。我确信那个人不在塔吉特工作了。不是那个空调维修工，可能依然是那个把它们放在同一个网络里的人。你知道的，一旦那些信用卡号被盗并且这些信用卡被使用，就会向塔吉特收取
back to Target. Like the customer, the credit card user is just like, Hey, wait a minute. These aren't real. Like, or. Or how did they get my information? Is it because of Target? Target was the last place I bought something and then all this stuff showed up. So you can see how it's a little convoluted to the consumer, the end user of these computers, like what was really at stake for me, whereas like it's going to become more real for, for people today because of the connectedness and the cryptocurrency realm. And I'm talking about not using exchanges. That's different. That's more like what we're used to, but I'm saying like, like having a wallet and storing the primitives.
退单（chargeback）。就像客户、信用卡用户会说：“嘿，等等。这些不是真的。或者，他们是怎么得到我的信息的？是因为塔吉特吗？塔吉特是我买东西的最后一个地方，然后所有这些账单都出现了。”所以你可以看到，对于消费者、这些计算机的最终用户来说，到底是什么东西处于危险之中，这有点令人费解。然而，由于互联性和加密货币领域的兴起，这对今天的人们来说将变得更加真实。我说的是不使用交易所的情况。那是另一回事，那更像是我们习惯的模式，但我的意思是拥有一个钱包并存储原语。
Yeah. I think the interesting two things I would say like from listening to that about cryptocurrency, which we reference obliquely all the time because it's a hot topic. But I'll say that this thing you mentioned about bridge is the interesting part too, is you don't need to put a bounty on them because the bounty is already there.
是的。我想从听取关于加密货币的讨论中说出两个有趣的事情，我们总是含沙射影地提到它，因为它是一个热门话题。但我会说，你提到的关于桥接（bridge）的这个事情也是有趣的部分，你不需要为它们悬赏，因为赏金已经存在了。
Like the money is already there. So like there are people financially incentivized to game theoretically to attack those things and to find the vulnerabilities and make themselves enormously rich, right? So like it's this very like high stakes, deep copy game, as you kind of mentioned, like if you transfer that thing, you own that thing and sort of them rolling it back, which is a whole other thing we could talk about in decentralization. But you're right.
钱已经在那里了。所以有一些人出于经济激励、博弈论去攻击这些东西，寻找漏洞并让自己变得极其富有，对吧？所以这是一个非常高风险、深拷贝的游戏，正如你所提到的，如果你转移了那个东西，你就拥有了那个东西，而不是回滚它——关于去中心化，我们还可以讨论很多。但你是对的。
I think that's really interesting. And the second thing is the amount of sort of game theory economics that I hear software engineers talk about, okay, Jason, if you go back and listen to the show, 10 years has been talking about economics and his curiosity. But like now, I feel it brings those things a lot more to the forefront where people are engaging in a broader space of society than just I write my program, it compiles, I do my web thing and i go home and i think outside of startups people in big corporations which i'm included you can sometimes shelter yourself that you just write your code and it's this little you know widget in the big thing
我认为这真的很有趣。第二件事是，我听到软件工程师谈论的博弈论经济学数量——好吧，杰森（Jason），如果你回去听这个节目，10年里一直在谈论经济学和他的好奇心。但现在，我觉得它把这些事情更多地推到了最前沿，人们正在参与一个更广泛的社会空间，而不仅仅是我编写程序、它能编译、我做我的网页事情然后回家。而且我认为除了初创公司之外，大公司里的人——包括我在内——有时可以让自己受到庇护，你只是编写你的代码，这只是大局中的一个小部件。
and i think in cryptocurrency whatever not it's good or bad net but like this fact that software engineers think more broadly about societal impacts, I think is a good thing. I think like what will happen will happen, but that broader thinking, I think it's not good. Yeah.
我认为在加密货币中，无论它是好是坏，但软件工程师更广泛地思考社会影响这一事实，我认为是一件好事。我认为将要发生的事情会发生，但这种更广泛的思考，我认为不是坏事。是的。
They also, they, um, NeurIPS, which is a conference for, uh, for, um,
他们还在——NeurIPS，这是一个关于神经网络、人工智能和这一切的会议，他们实际上强迫——或者说不是强迫，但他们在规范中规定，所有提交给NeurIPS的文章都应该有一节关于社会影响（societal impact）的内容。所以这确实把它推到了最前沿。
neural networks and AI and all of this, they actually forced, uh, or not forced, but they, they put in their spec that all the submissions to NeurIPS ought to have a section on societal impact. And so it's really kind of bringing it to the forefront.
所以我的意思是，现在这是每个人都必须意识到的事情。
So I mean, it's something everyone has to be aware of now. Yeah, I think that's so prescient, right? Like people still want to talk about like cybersecurity and computer security, network security is like this specialized thing. Today, in 2022, the vast majority of crimes are committed online. Like way more pervasive than, you know, armed robbery ever was. It's just because you can automate it, you can scale it out on these hyperscaler cloud infrastructures. Yeah. Have you seen the meme about that?
是的，我认为这太有远见了，对吧？人们仍然想把网络安全、计算机安全、网络安全当作一件很专业的事情来谈论。今天，在2022年，绝大多数犯罪都是在网上进行的。这比以往任何持械抢劫都要普遍得多。这只是因为你可以将其自动化，可以在这些超大规模云基础设施上进行扩展。是的。你见过关于这个的那个梗吗？
There's this meme where it says, organized crime in the 1920s. It's these Sicilian gangsters with the bowler hats and everything. And it's like organized crime in 2020 is just a call center. Okay. Well, you had perfectly teed up a segue for intrusion detection and prevention and trying to do pattern matching. And I heard it coming, you had the perfect teed up segue to search. And I kind of busted it because I wanted to kind of talk that. So I'll retee it up for you. You were talking about, you know, sort of looking at signatures of payloads and packets and trying to understand and compare and how it's a very difficult problem. And so maybe we can pick it back up there. Yeah, it's like the home network was especially hard to try
有一个梗是这样的：20世纪20年代的有组织犯罪。那是戴着圆顶礼帽和其他东西的西西里黑帮。然后是2020年的有组织犯罪，它只是一个呼叫中心。好了，你刚刚完美地为入侵检测和预防以及尝试进行模式匹配做好了铺垫。我听到它要来了，你为搜索做好了完美的铺垫。而我有点把它搞砸了，因为我想聊聊那个。所以我再为你铺垫一次。你刚才在谈论——你知道的——查看载荷和数据包的签名，并试图理解和比较，这是一个非常困难的问题。所以也许我们可以从那里重新捡起来。是的，家庭网络尤其难围绕它建立业务，因为它们太不一样了。就像每个家庭网络都不同，你知道的，有些人是Xbox家庭，有些人是PlayStation家庭，不，有些人是Oculus家庭，有些人是HoloLens，你知道，Xbox、Oculus、PlayStation、Nintendo Switch，他们什么都有，为了老天爷，甚至还有一个智能烤箱，你知道的，还有一个真空低温烹调机（sous vide）——我永远搞不懂。是的，所以要将噪音与高保真威胁指标区分开来是非常困难的。
to build a business around because they're so different. Like every home network is different you know some people are xbox families some people are playstation families no so some people are oculus families some people are hololens you know xbox oculus playstation nintendo switch they got everything plus like a smart toaster for crying out loud you know and and like a sous vide like i never get it yes uh and so it was like differentiating noise from you know a high fidelity threat indicator was extremely difficult. Doing it in a structured manner was practically impossible for it to be cost efficient. And so search sort of, it did two things. One thing was it enabled a broader swath of analysts, right? So like people who didn't necessarily know a query language, you know, in terms of the JSON API or the syntax and MQL,
以结构化的方式做到这一点，实际上是不可能做到成本效益的。因此，搜索做了两件事。一件事是它使更广泛的分析师能够使用，对吧？所以对于那些不一定懂查询语言的人——就JSON API或语法以及MQL而言——
like they just needed to use a search box or a few search fields. And then the other one was there were so many different fields, like there's no unified schema like we can sort of enforce one in terms of what we're like sending from from our linux devices like we have like initially just lua like writing whatever was in standard out from the ids to the central repository and then later the system we were working on was just like throw everything in Then standard out from the IDS to the central repository. And then later, the system we were working on was just like throw everything in Elasticsearch. Some fields we knew about, some fields we didn't know about. And to filter on like a non-deterministic number of fields in a performant fashion, Apache Lucene, the subsystem there, was really powerful
他们只需要使用一个搜索框或几个搜索字段。另一个原因是，有太多不同的字段，没有统一的模式，我们可以从我们的Linux设备发送的内容中强制执行一种——比如我们最初只有Lua，将IDS中的标准输出写入中央存储库，然后后来我们正在处理的系统就像是把所有东西都扔进Elasticsearch。有些字段我们知道，有些字段我们不知道。为了以高性能的方式对数量不确定的字段进行过滤，Apache Lucene（其中的子系统）非常强大，对于那种工作、对于日志探索以及在数百万、数十亿日志的海草中寻找一根针或几根针，它依然非常强大。所以你提到的这种带有不确定字段的日志数据，我的意思是，我想这触及了人们经常谈论的结构化数据与非结构化数据之间的区别。因此，这种具有固定长度和固定事物的字段，如果你以非常、非常、非常标准的方式发出日志，
and remains really powerful for that kind of work, for log exploration and for, you know, finding a needle or a couple needles in a haystack of several million logs, several billion logs. So this sort of like log data you're mentioning with indeterminate fields, I mean, I guess that gets at people kind of talk about this difference between structured data versus unstructured data. So this kind of fields and set length and set things would be if you were emitting your logs in a very, very, very standard fashion,
那么也许搜索时间范围或其他东西会非常容易。但如果你对其中的一部分没有控制权，但你仍在收集并查看它，这就是你会开始使用像Lucene这样的东西的地方？是的，我会这么说。但即使你将其结构化，如果有许多不同的组合，并且你想向拥有长长可查找内容列表的人提供访问权限——比如成千上万个潜在的搜索查询——那么Lucene对这些也很好。所以I总以为Lucene——我想我搞错了，但这没关系。我承认。所以我一直认为Lucene是——我知道它比这更复杂，但我会说
then maybe searching for a time range or whatever would be pretty easy. But if you don't have control over some of that, but you're still collecting it up and looking, that's where you would start to use something like Lucene? Yes, I would say so. But even if you structured it, if there were a lot of different combinations and you wanted to give access to people who had a long list of things they could look for, like maybe thousands and thousands of potential search queries, then Lucene would also be good for that. So I always kind of thought Lucene, and I guess I'm wrong, but that's okay. I'll admit it. So I always thought Lucene was, I knew more sophisticated than this, but what I would say
我所了解的有点像是模糊匹配（fuzzy matching），也就是我输入一个查询词，而不是像我一开始提到的那种“等于等于”的东西——我们都是从那种方式开始的——它在做一些更多一点、花哨一点的事情，好吧，花哨得多。但你所说的不仅仅是那个，也许它确实做了那个。但它也做这种你可以输入更多自由格式文本并在数据的不同字段之间进行搜索的事情。是的，没错。我认为模糊匹配是一个重要的点，因为它回到了让更多人——在这种情况下是更广泛的分析师用户群体，或者SOC员工（安全运营中心员工）——使用搜索。这是因为Lucene实现了
I kind of knew as fuzzy matching, which is like I put in a query term and rather than this. But what I would say I kind of knew as fuzzy matching, which is like, I put in a query term, and rather than this equals equals thing, like I was mentioning in the beginning, which is how we all kind of start, like it was doing something a little bit more and a little bit fancy, okay, a lot fancier. But what you're saying is something more than that, maybe it does that. But it also does this like, more freeform text that you can input and sort of going over across the different fields of your data. Yeah, that's right. I think the fuzzy matching is an important point, though, because it goes back to like letting more people like a broader user base of analysts in this case, maybe or SOC employees, security operations center employees like search. And that's because Lucene implements
多麦尔-莱文斯坦编辑距离算法（Dommerall-Levenstein edit distance algorithm），用于以高性能的方式确定一个词条（token）是否在你的语料库或搜索文本（比如你的集合）中存在着小于或等于二的编辑距离。如果它小于或等于二，它可以快速纠正该查询以找到你原本打算打的字。这就是模糊匹配的工作原理。所以，假设你有一个基于湾区的公司列表，湾区可能有几千家公司，Google是其中之一。但你在手机上，也许你的手指像我一样粗。
the Dommerall-Levenstein edit distance algorithm for determining in a performant manner if token is an edit distance of less than or equal to two away from what exists in your corpus or your search text, like your collection. If it's less than or equal than two, it can quickly correct that query to find which you intended to type. That's how the fuzzy works. So like, say you have a list of companies based in the Bay Area, maybe a few thousand companies based in the Bay Area, and Google is one of them. But you're on your phone and maybe your fingers are fat like mine.
所以你输入了G-P-P-G-L-E。如果你把其中一个P改成O，那是编辑距离为1。我们进行了一次编辑。你把另一个也改成O，现在你是2了，你已经达到了最大值，但你现在匹配到了Google，这就是Lucene开箱即用就能做的事情，它在这方面相当不错。我没见过——你知道——还有什么其他系统像它那样被如此广泛地传播、如此广泛地用于该目的。我想现在我们正在塑造搜索领域，如果我们有一个数据库，也许人们见过一个SQL查询，你无法说出“我想要行，其等于Google并且它匹配了gpple”——所以我们已经在
So you type G-P-P-G-L-E. If you change one of those P's to an O, that's an edit distance of one. We've made one edit. You change the other other one to oh now you're at two you've maxed out but you match google now and so that's something that lucene does out of the box it's pretty good at that uh i haven't seen you know any other system as widely spread as widely used rather for that purpose i guess now we're sort of shaping up like the field of search i guess we're kind of entering that like if we have like a database and maybe people have seen like a sql query where you're not going to be able to say like i want rows which equals google and it matched gpple right so we're already
谈论多了一个复杂度的层级，你有点像——我们称之为行扫描（row scanning），也就是遍历每一行并寻找东西。但我想你所说的一些事情可以通过行扫描来完成，但你也需要做某种预索引，感觉这就是我们从一个程序员在做其他事情、顺便加上它并试图找到某些东西，转变为了——我们称之为——一个研究领域，变得更加复杂并构建系统。我对这个领域的理解对吗？我不知道。做搜索的人——经常做搜索的人——是如何谈论不同的索引类型的？比如B树（B-trees）已经存在很长时间了，它们存在于现有的数据库中，它们允许你
talking about like one layer of more sophistication, where you're sort of like, let's just call it row scanning, like going through every row and looking for stuff. But I guess like some of these things you're saying could be done there row scanning, but also you needing to do sort of some kind of pre indexing and sort of it, it feels like this is where we move from like, a programmer doing something else who tacked it on and is trying to find something to a sort of like, let's call it like a field of study, like something more sophisticated and building up the systems. Do I kind of have that space right? Like, I don't know. How do people who do search like kind of talk about search that do it often talk about the differing index types. So like B-trees have been around for a while and those existing databases and they allow you
相当高效、相当快地根据某个字段和一些匹配标准精确定位（pinpoint）某一行。倒排索引（Inverted index）则将它颠倒过来，就像你在一个词袋（bag of words）中寻找，并试图在集合中找到包含某个词的所有文档、索引中的所有文档。这里有排名，TF-IDF。我的意思是，今天大多数人使用BM25，其中TF-IDF是其中的一部分。TF-IDF是指词频除以逆文档频率（term frequency over inverse document frequency）。所以你可以这样想：如果Marcus出现在1000个文档语料库中的一个文档里，但Marcus在该文档中出现了好几次，那个文档的排名会比任何——它将是唯一呈现的文档，因为Marcus出现在那里而且出现了好几次；但如果Jason也出现在那里，但也出现在另一个文档中，也许Jason
to pinpoint, you know, a row based on a field and some matching criteria pretty efficiently, pretty fast. Inverted index kind of turns it on its head where like you're looking through a bag of words and you're trying to find all the documents in a collection, all the documents in an index that contain some word. And there's ranking, TFIDF. I mean, most people use BM25 today, which TFIDF is a part of that. TFIDF is, that's referring to term frequency over inverse document frequency. So you can think about if Marcus appears in one document in a 1000 document corpus, but Marcus appears several times in that document, that document is going to be surface higher than any, it's going to be the only document surface because Marcus appears there and many times, but if Jason appears there, but also appears in another document, maybe the Jason
关于你的那个文档——所以你在这个文档中作为我出现过的节目的一位联合主持人和Marcus文档一起出现，但你在Jason文档中出现了好多次，而你搜索Jason，你出现好多次的那个文档将排在第一位。然后Marcus的文档将排在第二位，因为你在第二个文档中出现得更多。这与文档频率有关，但是像“the”这个词——不会——不会对我们两个中的任何一个产生强烈的排名关键词或搜索标准，因为逆文档频率——它因为存在于每个文档中而受到惩罚。所以大多数人在大多数用例中都会把它剔除，
document about you, like, so you appear in this document as the co-host of a show that I appeared on in the Marcus document, but you appear in the Jason document many times and you search for Jason, the document where you appear many times will appear first. And then the Marcus document will appear second because you appear more in that second document. And it's about document frequency, but like the, the word, the would not write, like would not be a strongly ranking keyword or search criterion for either of us because the inverse document frequency, like it's punished by the fact that it's in every document. And so most people will pull that one out
因为它会被归类为停用词（stop word）。哦，所以这在——我不知道是哪一年，但比如早期的搜索浏览器、搜索引擎中是不行的，也就是说，你去网站，你输入你正在寻找的文档——我猜在这种情况下，那会是网页——最后你会遇到那些在网页背景相同颜色的地方把同一个词重复了一千遍的人，这就是他们试图作弊的方法，他们试图让某个词在他们的网页中出现得更频繁，从而使它在搜索结果中上升。所以，我明白了。这非常有趣。当你谈到像停用词这样的东西时，我们谈到了Marcus，我们之前也讨论过这一点，但它有点涉及到理解人们语言的结构。就像人们正常地说话、正常地打字进搜索框，而不是根据他们认为文档里有什么来精心策划他们的搜索。所以，作为一个程序员，如果我要搜索可编程的东西，我会输入一个非常特定的枚举名称或类似的东西。但在这里，我们是说如果人们在使用像“duh”这样的词，他们是在正常说话，他们只是把他们会在搜索引擎里说的话写下来。
in most use cases because it'll be categorized as a stop word. Oh, so this is not okay in the, I have no idea what year, but like early search browser, research engines, let's say, which you go to website you type in you're looking for documents i guess in this case that would be web pages and you end up with those people at the bottom who would put like the same word repeated like a thousand times in the same color as the background of the web page or whatever this is what they were trying to gain is they were trying to make a certain word appear far more often in their webpage so that it would go up the search results. So, okay. I see. That's very interesting. And when you say stuff like stop
是的。我认为这抓住了我认为是搜索的核心，是什么驱使这么多人进行搜索并使其对我如此引人入胜。许多人所期望的——
words, and we're like Marcus, and we were talking about this a bit before, but it kind of gets into a little bit understanding the structure of people's language. Like people talking normally into this, typing normally into the search box, rather than sort of curating what they're searching to what they think is in the documents. So like, as a programmer, if I was going to search something programmable, like I would type in a very specific enum name or something. But here, we're saying if people are using the word duh, they're kind of talking normally, they're just sort of writing what they would say into the search engine. Yeah. And I think that gets what I think is the heart of search, what drives so many people to search and makes it so compelling to me. What many people hope for,
有些人明确不希望这样，但许多人希望的是：计算机能够体现出许多人类的特征，这样它们就可以在某些事情上帮助我们。比如，我不想粉刷我的房间。我想要我的计算机来做。我不想——你知道的，其中之一——我不想做作业。我想要我的计算机来做。我不想做晚饭。我想要我的计算机来做。我不想开车。我想要我的计算机来做。所以，自动驾驶的领头羊是Waymo，这并非巧合——Waymo现在是世界上最大搜索公司的子公司、分拆公司，对吧？或者计算机视觉，它也源于搜索。这是因为有了搜索，你可以与
some people don't explicitly don't want this, but many people hope for is that computers can embody many human characteristics so they can help us with things. Like, I don't want to paint my room. I want my computer to do it. I don't, you know, one of them, you know, I don't want to do my homework. I want my computer to do it. I don't want to cook dinner. I want my computer to do it. I don't want to drive. I want my computer to do it. I don't want to drive. I want my computer to do it. And so like, it's no coincidence that like the leader in autonomous driving is Waymo, which is a subsidiary spinoff at this point, spinoff of the largest search company in the world, right? Or Computer Vision, which also came out of search. It's because with search, you can interface with
计算机进行交互，就像你日常生活中与人类交互一样。人类如此特别的原因在于我们能够沟通。我听到的就是这样。所以也许我们可以改善我们的沟通，但在一个你可以与计算机交谈并获得有意义回应的世界里，这是非常强大的，也是搜索的核心。Alexa，Siri，它们在某种程度上都由Lucene提供支持。今天的赞助商是Mergify。Mergify是一个针对GitHub的工具，它可以对你的拉取请求（pull request）进行优先级排序、排队、自动合并、评论、变基（rebase）、更新、打标签、回花（backport）、关闭和分配。
the computer in a way that you interface with humans day to day. What makes humans so special is the ability for us to communicate. That's what I hear anyway. So maybe we could improve our communication, but in a world where you can talk to your computers and get like meaningful responses is really powerful and at the heart of search. Alexa, Siri, they're both powered, you know, to some extent by Lucene. Today's sponsor is Mergify. Mergify is a tool for GitHub that prioritizes, queues, automatically merges, comments, rebases, updates, labels, backports, closes, and assigns your pull requests.
Mergify的功能允许你自动化那些你通常需要手动去做的事情。你可以使用合并队列（merge queue）来保护你的代码，自动合并它，以及更多功能。通过节省时间，你和你的团队可以专注于重要的项目。Mergify可以与任何CI协调，并完全集成到GitHub中。他们有一个初创公司项目，可以为你的公司提供12个月的信用额度来利用Mergify。这相当于高达21,000美元的价值。
Mergify features allow you to automate what you would normally do manually. You can secure your code using a merge queue, automatically merge it, and many more features. By saving time, you and your team can focus on projects that matter. Mergify can coordinate with any CI and is fully integrated into GitHub. They have a startup program that could give your company a 12-month credit to leverage Mergify. That's up to $21,000 of value.
开始节省时间。访问Mergify.com注册演示并开始使用。或者直接点击节目说明中的链接。回到正题。好吧，那么Lucene能在那里提供帮助吗？所以当你这么说时，我会把字母TF-IDF弄混。你有点在说：我拿了写下来的文字，也许你允许编辑距离。但现在当你开始说“我们像人类一样交谈和交流”时，我开始想到诸如“意义”或“语义”之类的事情，或者我说了一个术语，而我想要的东西甚至可能根本不包含我打出来的词。
Start saving time. Visit Mergify.com to sign up for a demo and get started. Or just follow the link in the show notes. Back to the episode. Okay, so does Lucene help there? So when you say this, I'm going to mess up the letters T F IDF. And you're sort of saying like, I'm taking the words written, maybe you allow for edit distance. But now when you start to say, like, we talk as humans and communicate, I start to think like meaning or semantics or like I'm saying a term and the thing that I want may not actually even contain the words I typed in. Yeah, I think this is such a good question because I think about it all the time. We talk about it internally all the time here at my company and on our team. And that is like inferring
是的，我认为这是一个很好的问题，因为我无时无刻不在思考这个问题。我们公司内部、我们团队内部也总是在谈论这个。那就是推断
human intent and inferring customer intent, user intent. it's a bit of a dark art. You have to know something about that person to know where they're coming from, like their perspective. So what makes surfacing this data for a user that's relevant to them before they even know what they're looking for, that's kind of what you're talking about. It's like find something based on criteria that doesn't even exist in the corpus is it's all context driven. Right. So if you ever go to like Safari for the first time or if you're paranoid and only use incognito, like they'll ask you, do you want to allow Google to know your location? And it's interesting. A lot of people, most people are going to say allow. Some people are going to say don't allow. But if you say allow,
人类的意图和推断客户的意图、用户的意图。这有点像一门暗黑艺术。你必须对这个人有所了解，才知道他们的背景，比如他们的视角。因此，在用户甚至不知道自己在找什么之前，就为他们呈现与之相关的数据——这正是你所谈论的。就像根据甚至不存在于语料库中的标准来寻找某些东西，这完全是上下文驱动的。对吧。所以如果你曾经第一次访问Safari，或者如果你有偏觉并且只使用隐身模式，他们会问你：你想允许Google知道你的位置吗？这很有趣。许多人——大多数人会说允许。有些人会说不允许。但如果你说允许，
the likelihood is that the relevance of the results that Google shows you will increase. Because if you search, let's say, Chinese food and Google knows you're on 52nd and Broadway, it's going to show you Chinese food in Manhattan near 52nd and Broadway. It's not going to show you like the really dank spots and flushing. You know, there are some really good spots if you want to hike, but like it's going to show you like those spots are going to be considered because they're rated so high. But the weight of proximity, geo proximity will pull these other restaurants nearby and even some restaurants that aren't necessarily Chinese restaurants and just have dishes with similar ingredients are also going to surface. So to riff on this, because I think I thought about this before, too, is if you typed in Paris bakery and the search engine knows nothing about you, should it show you bakeries in Paris? Probably. you like bakeries in Paris, probably like probably like without knowing anything about you, it should
Google向你展示的结果的相关性就会增加的可能性更大。因为如果你搜索——比方说——中餐，而Google知道你在第52街和百老汇（Broadway），它会向你展示曼哈顿第52街和百老汇附近的中餐。它不会向你展示——比如法拉盛（Flushing）那些真正很棒的苍蝇馆子。你知道，如果你想远足，那里有一些非常不错的地方——但它会展示——那些地方会被考虑到，因为它们的评分很高。但是地理邻近性的权重会将附近的其他餐馆拉进来，甚至一些不一定是中餐厅、只是含有相似配料的菜肴的餐馆也会浮现出来。为了就此展开讨论——因为我以前也考虑过这个问题——如果你输入“巴黎面包店”，而搜索引擎对你一无所知，它应该向你展示巴黎的面包店吗？可能应该。你喜欢巴黎的面包店，可能——可能在对你一无所知的情况下，它应该这么做。
go to Paris and find whatever using all these things you said, like give you bakery results. But if you're like, I don't know, around where I was in the Bay Area, there was like a restaurant called Paris Bakery. And so if it knows I'm in the Bay Area, rather than showing me something which could have been what I was looking for. But like Paris bakery should probably match to the restaurant named Paris bakery. But if I'm in Iowa, and there's no Paris bakery, it probably should still show me the ones in France, not the one in California, that's a relatively like unknown, you know, kind of minor restaurant, not a famous restaurant or anything. And so I think that dynamic you point out is like really interesting. Like, it's more than just knowing at a human level that like, these words mean this thing, but that meaning isn't universal. A human at a certain time in
去巴黎，利用你说的所有这些东西找到任何东西，比如给你面包店的结果。但如果你像我一样，在湾区我待过的地方附近，有一家叫巴黎面包店的餐馆。所以如果它知道我在湾区，而不是给我展示一些可能是我在找的东西。但像巴黎面包店这样的名字，可能应该匹配到那家名叫巴黎面包店的餐馆。但如果我在爱荷华州，那里没有巴黎面包店，它大概还是应该给我显示法国的那些，而不是加州的那个。那是个相对不太知名、有点像小型餐馆的地方，不是什么著名的餐馆。所以我觉得你指出的这种动态变化真的很有趣。这不仅仅是在人类的层面上去理解这些词代表什么意思，而是这种含义并不是通用的。在某个时间的
a certain place saying those words mean something different than another human in another time in another place. Yeah, that's right. And like, I think a lot of people think about search in the context of Google, which is like a generalized search engine, you know, sort of like Bing. I haven't used Bing in several years, but like, I think Bing's still out there. Yeah. Like the problem changes if it's a domain specific search. So if you're building a search for your application, right, because Paris and a restaurant search app or a recipe search app or, you know, something like along this line or even a movie search app, Paris might be a synonym for France or Parisian, French. And so then Paris bakery also means France bakery and French bakery. And for sure, there's many French bakeries everywhere because the pastries are-
某个地点说出这些话的人，和在另一个时间和另一个地点说这些话的人，意思是不一样的。是的，没错。而且我觉得很多人在谷歌的语境下思考搜索，谷歌就像是一个广义的搜索引擎，有点像必应。我好几年没用过必应了，不过我觉得必应还在吧。是的。如果这是一个特定领域的搜索，问题就会发生变化。所以如果你在为你的应用构建搜索，没错，因为在餐馆搜索应用、食谱搜索应用、或者类似的应用、甚至电影搜索应用中，“巴黎”可能是法国（France）或巴黎人（Parisian）、法国的（French）的同义词。所以“巴黎面包店”也意味着法国面包店和法式面包店。而且肯定到处都有很多法式面包店，因为这些糕点——
Or anywhere that serves croissants, yeah. Yeah, right, right. But there still are French bakeries, even Parisian bakeries in places in the United States and obviously all over France and Paris. I was just going to say, so maybe if we think about like, you know, I'm an engineer, I'm building my program, I start to collect a whole bunch of data, you know, and I want,
或者任何供应牛角面包的地方，对吧。对，没错，没错。但美国各地以及法国和巴黎显然到处都还是有法式面包店，甚至是巴黎面包店。我刚才正想说，所以如果我们考虑一下，比如说，我是个工程师，我正在构建我的程序，我开始收集大量的数据，然后我希望，
like you said, either users or analysts need to be able to interact with all the data I'm gathering. I guess I should have picked a specific example, but I didn't. And sort of, I know something about my domain. I know I want to allow this sort of semantic kind of searching to take place and fuzzy matching and really empower people to interact and surface results that they want from my specific thing. How do I go, like, what is the what is the trajectory I would normally go along? So first, you might do like a text search and SQL query, we talked about this, like, what is the kind of arc of how that happens as an engineer starts to
就像你说的，无论是用户还是分析师都需要能够与我收集的所有数据进行交互。我想我本该举个具体的例子，但我没有。而且某种程度上，我对我的领域有所了解。我知道我想让这种语义搜索能够进行，进行模糊匹配，真正赋能人们进行交互，并从我的特定内容中呈现他们想要的结果。我该如何进行，通常会经历怎样的发展轨迹呢？首先，你可能会做一个文本搜索和SQL查询，我们讨论过这个，当一个工程师开始
build up a set of things they want to search? Yeah. So, so the first thing is like indexing and running your first query, just like default index, index, run your first query, have an experience feeling it. Like I'm a big proponent of like, as a product manager, really focusing on how it feels to use a product, right? Because I've been in the place and I spend 20% of my time doing this today, continuing to do this, like banging my head into a wall, like trying to really get at it. And when I do that, I get a sense of where there's opportunity to improve. So when you are setting out to build that, you need to do it. You need to bang your head really quickly, index some data, query that index, understand the output, the format of the output, the information,
构建一组他们想要搜索的内容时，整个过程的发展脉络是怎样的？好的。所以，第一件事就是索引并运行你的第一个查询，就像默认的索引一样，建立索引，运行你的第一个查询，通过实际体验来感受一下。我非常支持作为一名产品经理，要真正专注于使用产品时的感觉，对吧？因为我曾经身处那个位置，今天我仍有20%的时间在做这件事，并且会继续做下去，就像把头撞在墙上一样，试图真正搞清楚它。当我这么做的时候，我就会对哪里有改进的机会有所感悟。所以当你着手构建它时，你必须亲自动手。你需要狠狠地把头撞几次，给一些数据建立索引，查询那个索引，理解输出结果、输出结果的格式、相关信息，
the metadata that you have exposed or available to you. Then secondly, you need to refine that index to make it more suitable or useful for your use case, right? So that might include pointers to a few synonyms collections. That might include language-specific analyzers like English or French to strip away the stop words and handle the diacritics appropriately. Diacritics are like those those squiggly lines under the sea in France. Today I learned. Or like the accent over. The A and Ola, I think that's right. And in Spanish. And so the next thing, once you kind of you understand like what your language analyzers are, you have your synonyms collection and your maybe some facet fields for the low cardinality fields, low cardinality is just like how many unique values are in an index in a corpus. So, for example, for imagine a movie search engine, there's only like five or six genres
以及你已经公开或可用的元数据。其次，你需要优化那个索引，使其更适合或更有用于你的用例，对吧？所以这可能包括指向一些同义词集合的指针。这可能包括特定语言的分析器，比如英语或法语分析器，用来去除停用词并正确处理变音符号。变音符号就像法国字“c”下面那些弯弯曲曲的线条。今天学到了。或者像字母上面的重音。比如“Hola”里的字母A，我想是这样的。还有西班牙语。所以接下来，一旦你理解了你的语言分析器是什么，你有了同义词集合，可能还有针对低基数字段的一些分面（facet）字段，低基数只是指一个索引或语料库中有多少个唯一值。例如，想象一个电影搜索引擎，只有大约五六种类型，
like comedy, horror, drama, fantasy, thriller, you know, something like that. So romance. So like or bromance, you know, like that so romance so like or bromance you know not like you want to make that a facet field because those are fields that the customers can filter on even though there are a hundred thousand movies that's a good candidate because it's low cardinality relative to the number of documents to help you whittle down to what your customer help your customers find what they're looking for. But so once you've tried it, you've made an index,
比如喜剧、恐怖、剧情、奇幻、惊悚，诸如此类。还有爱情。所以或者兄弟情，你知道的，所以是爱情，所以或者兄弟情，不是说你想把它变成一个分面字段，因为那些是客户可以进行过滤的字段，尽管有十万部电影，这仍然是一个很好的候选，因为它相对于文档数量来说基数很低，能帮你缩小范围，帮你的客户找到他们寻找的东西。但是，一旦你尝试过了，你创建了一个索引，
the third step, if you're building a really sophisticated system now, like I'm kind of like the third step could be go build your UI. You know, like if you're building a sophisticated system, the third step would be to start to try to understand the queries. So what's interesting about the Paris bakery example is for a sophisticated system,
第三步，如果你现在正在构建一个非常复杂的系统，就像我说的，第三步可能是去构建你的用户界面（UI）。你知道，如果你在构建一个复杂的系统，第三步将是开始试图理解查询。所以巴黎面包店的例子有趣的地方在于，对于一个复杂系统来说，
it might tag Paris as a location and bakery as a geolocation they might like draw a polygon even on the map like it had lucene has these capabilities like it has via the lat long query parser it can draw a polygon really for paris yeah for paris and you know you can read about you know tessellation and and lucene another day it's a like a topic of a phd probably actually i think a few people have done their phds on this field but like nick knizey i think is one. But like, yeah, you can draw a bound. You can draw a box. That is Paris. That's a polygon. And then bakery is a point of interest. So you got this geolocation and you got this point of interest. Bakery is a place. That's that's stuff like that's a thing. Paris is the constraint on it.
它可能会把“巴黎”标记为一个位置，把“面包店”标记为一个地理位置，它们甚至可以在地图上画一个多边形——比如Lucene就有这些功能，它可以通过经纬度（lat long）查询解析器真正为巴黎在地图上画出一个多边形，是的，为巴黎画出来。你可以去了解一下关于镶嵌（tessellation）和Lucene的其他知识，那可能是个博士生课题，事实上我觉得确实有几个人在这个领域读了博士。不过尼克·克奈兹（Nick Knize）我想是其中之一。但是，是的，你可以画一个边界。你可以画一个框。那就是巴黎。那是一个多边形。然后面包店是一个兴趣点（POI）。所以你有这个地理位置，还有这个兴趣点。面包店是一个地方。那就是诸如此类的一个实体。巴黎是对它的约束。
And so how you understand that query shapes like what results are returned. So you have a geo, like a geo constraint. That would be a filter. You're only showing bakeries in Paris and in bakery would be like a must have condition. So like bakery must appear in these documents in my corpus. And Paris is the only place where I'm looking. This is in one use case. Like it depends on what your application is. And so Paris, like, I mean, what you'll see is there's some limitations that you will get some documents you don't care about.
所以你如何理解该查询，决定了会返回什么结果。所以你有一个地理约束。那将是一个过滤器。你只显示巴黎的面包店，而面包店将是一个必须具备的条件。就像面包店必须出现在我语料库的这些文档中一样。而巴黎是我正在寻找的唯一地方。这只是其中一个用例。这取决于你的应用是什么。所以巴黎，也就是说，你会发现有一些局限性，你会得到一些你并不关心的文档。
Like there's going to be grocery stores that have the word bakery in them. But you really wanted to go to like a specialty bakery. There's probably going to be coffee shops, cafes in that list because. Maybe baked goods or fresh from X bakery will surface. And so then like there's the next step once you have this query understanding, right, which is about taking the historical user data, like how people have interacted with their search results over time should influence like the future results. But like just so we're clear, understanding that query and constraining it to that geo field and then that point of interest that requires like a flexible schema, a flexible data model, right? So like right then and there, we know that a database, a relational database, like in a traditional sense,
比如会有一些杂货店，里面包含“面包店”这个词。但你真正想去的是那种特色面包店。那个列表中可能也会有咖啡店、咖啡馆，因为。可能会浮现出“烘焙食品”或“来自X面包店的新鲜食品”。所以接下来，一旦你有了这种查询理解，对吧，这关乎利用历史用户数据，比如人们随着时间推移与搜索结果的交互方式，应该会影响未来的结果。但为了让我们说清楚，理解该查询并将其限制在那个地理字段，然后再加上那个兴趣点，这需要一个灵活的模式（schema）、一个灵活的数据模型，对吧？所以就在此时此刻，我们知道数据库，传统意义上的关系型数据库，
it's just like not a good candidate for that. I mean, listen, I don't like, I know what these professors, some professors are saying at universities about this technology from the 60s, early 70s, about relational databases. They just don't fit the use case of modern computers today and how humans interface most of the time. Right.
它根本就不是一个好的候选。听着，我并不是，我知道大学里的某些教授是怎么评价这项来自60年代、70年代初的技术——关于关系型数据库的。它们根本不符合当今现代计算机的用例，也不符合人类绝大多数时候与计算机交互的方式。对吧。
Because and like Amazon, Google, they're not relying on relational databases much for these things. Right. They're using like this flexible data model that can evolve to meet your needs. Now we know our customers are querying by geo constraints. So we need a geo field, geo filter field even. Then now we know about this point of interest. So let's have a point of interest field.
因为像亚马逊、谷歌，它们在这些事情上并不是很依赖关系型数据库。对吧。它们使用的是这种能够随需应变演进的灵活数据模型。现在我们知道我们的客户是通过地理约束来进行查询的。所以我们需要一个地理字段，甚至是一个地理过滤字段。现在我们了解了这个兴趣点，所以让我们拥有一个兴趣点字段。
Once you have those, you take the user's interaction with the results to understand the quality and even segmenting those users, right? So some people like to store like a hash of every user. I mean, we know many companies that do that. I won't name their names. I think probably even more valid to have buckets like personas, segments, where these are living categorizations, where some people may be in one segment for part of their customer lifespan, and then they graduate or get demoted to a different segment or get moved around. Maybe all segments are considered equal, and they just get moved around over time as their interest and interaction history changes but that that feedback loop is so important to cultivating like uh uh improved relevance so you
一旦你有了这些，你就可以利用用户与结果的交互来了解质量，甚至对这些用户进行细分，对吧？所以有些人喜欢存储每个用户的哈希值。我的意思是，我们知道很多公司都在这样做。我就不点名了。我觉得更有价值的做法或许是拥有像角色、细分群体这样的存储桶，这些是动态的分类，有些人在其客户生命周期的某段时间可能属于某个细分群体，然后他们升级或降级到另一个细分群体，或者被调动。也许所有细分群体都被认为是的平等的，随着他们的兴趣和交互历史的变化，他们只是会随着时间推移被重新分配，但这种反馈循环对于培养提升相关性来说实在是太重要了，所以
have the you have the categorization uh like query understanding there's like lots of nlp libraries that can help you with that and different techniques to help you classification algorithms. Then the next one, you got the click history or the interaction history. Maybe sounds a little less scary or, you know. The interaction history, the engagement. What is driving success of your user and their journey? And then boost those results, those keywords. Then the next one, which is sort of a buzzword frontier that I really
你有分类，比如查询理解，有很多自然语言处理（NLP）库可以帮你做到这一点，还有不同的技术来帮助你实现分类算法。接下来，你有点击历史或交互历史。听起来可能不那么可怕，或者说。交互历史，参与度。是什么在推动你的用户和他们的旅程走向成功？然后提升那些结果、那些关键词。接下来，这是一个有点像是前沿热词的东西，我真的
caution people not to jump into too heavily, definitely not head first because it'll cost you. I think it's really important to try to understand those first few steps and then move to this step, right? So you could call all of, most of that you could categorize as lexical search, more or less, like matching, text matching, fuzzy matching, based on lexical criteria, how things appear. Like once they get through the analysis chain, that's once they've been mutated by Lucene analyzers for easier retrieval. So friendship, friendly, friends, all match friend,
告诫人们不要一头扎进去，绝对不要盲目地一头扎进去，因为那会让你付出代价。我认为非常重要的是，先试着理解前面那几个步骤，然后再转向这一步，对吧？所以你可以把所有这些、其中大部分都归类为词法搜索（lexical search），或多或少就是基于词法标准的匹配、文本匹配、模糊匹配，看事物是如何呈现的。就像它们穿过分析链之后，也就是它们被Lucene分析器进行过变异处理以便于检索之后。所以“friendship”、“friendly”、“friends”都匹配“friend”，
F-R-I-E-N, because that's the root, that's the stem of it. So once you get through the analysis, the indexing where it includes analysis to the query understanding, to like understanding your users and how they interact. Even maybe even some automated synonyms based on zero results, because nobody likes zero results. You go into a store, you ask them, hey, where are these pants? And, you know, because the customer service representative just walks away and doesn't come back and never answers your question. Like, you're going to let me walk out of here pantsless. Like, that's terrible. That's terrible.
即F-R-I-E-N，因为那是词根。所以一旦你经历了分析、包含分析的索引、查询理解，到理解你的用户以及他们如何交互。甚至可能还有基于零结果的一些自动化同义词，因为没有人喜欢零结果。你走进一家店，问他们，嘿，这条裤子在哪里？然后，由于客服代表直接走开并没有回来，也从未回答你的问题。就像，你要让我光着裤子从这里走出去吗？这太糟糕了。这太糟糕了。
Like, where are like if someone asks you a question, they they are counting on you for an answer. So like the zero results is like an area where I have seen people have a tremendous impact, just like automating synonym generation or just going in manually and adding synonyms for zero results. That's why I think the synonyms capability is so important. But once you get through all of this, let me wave my hands and get everybody excited. Right. It's like this era of semantic search. Right. Where I've been exploring one of the more challenging data sets to search for like explanations of concepts in search that are really advanced. So there's the one of the people you can blame for like Internet Explorer is the former product manager of Netscape. It's like Ben Horowitz.
就像，如果有人问你一个问题，他们指望你能给出一个答案。所以零结果是我看到人们能产生巨大影响的一个领域，只需自动化生成同义词，或者亲自去手动添加针对零结果的同义词。这就是为什么我认为同义词功能如此重要。但是一旦你经历了所有这些，让我挥舞双手让大家都兴奋起来。对吧。这就进入了语义搜索的时代。对吧。我一直在探索其中一个最具挑战性的数据集，用于搜索对搜索中非常先进的概念的解释。所以，你可以为因特网浏览器（Internet Explorer）背锅的人之一，就是网景（Netscape）的前产品经理。也就是本·霍洛维茨（Ben Horowitz）。
He's like also famous for making a ton of great investments and companies early and startups early. But back in the day, he was a product manager on uh and netscape and they invented i mean they popularized the web browser and he does this thing in many of his books where he starts with like a rap quote which i i love and so i'm trying to do that as well, starting like the most recent I've done is like 12, like 10 years ago, maybe. I'm trying, I mostly go further back than that.
他还以在早期对许多优秀公司和初创公司进行大量出色投资而闻名。但在当年，他是网景的产品经理，他们发明了——我的意思是他们普及了网络浏览器。他在他的许多书中都会这样做，他会以一句说唱歌词开头，我非常喜欢，所以我也在尝试这样做，从最近的我做过的大概是12年前、10年前吧。我在努力，我通常会追溯得更久远一些。
And one of the techniques, this literary technique and poetry for, you know, as long as poetry has been studied, really highlighted for me how semantic search works it just sort of reminded me so this is a big t-up i'm ready i'm ready yeah drake before he was famous he had this like uh mixtape and he's freestyling now he's the most famous probably i mean i don't get to listen to him that much anymore listen to things. A lot of old stuff these days in electronic music and classical music, but that's neither here nor there.
其中一种技巧，这种文学技巧和诗歌，对于（你知道的，只要有人研究诗歌就会发现）真正向我突显了语义搜索是如何工作的，它只是让我回想起这一点，所以这是一个巨大的铺垫，我准备好了，我准备好了。是的，德雷克（Drake）在他成名之前，有过这样一张混音带，他在即兴说唱。现在他是最著名的了，我的意思是，我已经不怎么听他的歌了，听别的东西去了。这几天听很多老歌，电子乐和古典乐，但这都是后话了。
Back in the day, he said, we're getting Seinfeld on some Jerry and Elaine queries. Let's just say he said queries. I replaced another word there. Thank you. And so we're getting Seinfeld documents on some Jerry and Elaine queries. And so what he was describing is really how our brains do associations, like how we find memories stored in our internal databases based on like cues or hints. And that's really how semantic search works. It's really
当年他说，我们在某些杰瑞（Jerry）和伊莱恩（Elaine）的查询中得到了《宋飞传》（Seinfeld）的文档。我们姑且说他说的是查询吧。我在那里替换了另一个词。谢谢。我们在某些杰瑞和伊莱恩的查询中得到了宋飞传的文档。所以他所描述的实际上是 我们的大脑是如何进行联想的，我们是如何根据线索或提示在内部数据库中找到存储的记忆的。这正是语义搜索的工作原理。它确实是
built on neural networks to train these language models that can then tell you that when Jerry and Elaine, two first names, appear together, you may actually be looking for Seinfeld because Jerry and Elaine are two characters in Seinfeld. So they occur together a lot. Like, so you train this language model on thousands and thousands, billions of documents, really billions of documents where humans have written texts, maybe it's scripts, maybe it's reviews, critiques. Maybe it's like like search applications for streaming. You know, you have all these corpora, this rich body of text that contain both Seinfeld and Jerry and Elaine. They might even say Jerry and Elaine Seinfeld. I don't know if that's their last names in the show. I don't watch the show. But even I, when I hear Jerry and Elaine,
建立在神经网络之上的，用来训练这些语言模型，然后这些语言模型可以告诉你，当杰瑞和伊莱恩这两个名字同时出现时，你实际上可能在找《宋飞传》，因为杰瑞和伊莱恩是《宋飞传》里的两个角色。所以他们经常一起出现。所以，你在成千上万、数十亿份文档上训练这个语言模型，真的是数十亿份人类编写过文本的文档，也许是剧本，也许是评论、批判。也许是像流媒体的搜索应用。你知道，你有所有这些语料库，这篇丰富的文本主体中同时包含《宋飞传》以及杰瑞和伊莱恩。他们甚至可能会说杰瑞、伊莱恩和宋飞传。我不知道那是不是他们在剧中的姓氏。我不看这部剧。但即使是我，当我听到杰瑞和伊莱恩时，
for some reason think Seinfeld. And so that's really what semantic search is about. Our team is working on releasing semantic search capabilities. I mean, they'll be out. They'll be available to users that like reach out to me. The reason why we're doing it like that is because I want feedback. I really want to guide people to success. I don't want them to just assume ML is going to be a panacea for their relevance or result
不知为何就会想到《宋飞传》。所以这正是语义搜索的意义所在。我们的团队正致力于发布语义搜索功能。我的意思是，它们会推出的。它们将向联系我的用户开放。我们之所以这样做的原因，是因为我想要反馈。我真的想引导人们走向成功。我不希望他们只是想当然地认为机器学习（ML）将成为他们相关性或结果排序问题的灵丹妙药，
ordering problems because that's not how it is. Like, it's really important for an engineer to remind themselves every day that ML doesn't always win. No, come on. Come on. Because, like, my grandmother was about she was about ready to throw her shoe at the autonomous driver of a car we were in, you know, in the Bay Area years ago. We rode in the car and it's like trying to make an unprotected left. It's like, grandma, grandma, like this is the first time it's had an incident. You know, aside from like dodging like one leaf sticking in the road, thinking it's an obstruction, like this is the only thing that was really a problem.
因为事实并非如此。对于一个工程师来说，每天提醒自己机器学习并不总是能赢，这非常重要。不，拜托。拜托。因为，就像我多年前在湾区时，我的祖母差点把她的鞋子扔向我们乘坐的那辆自动驾驶汽车的驾驶员。我们坐在车里，它正试图进行一次无保护的左转。就像，“奶奶，奶奶，这只是它第一次遇到这种状况。”除了躲避路上的一片叶子、误以为那是障碍物之外，这是唯一真正出问题的地方。
And I struggled to make unprotected left. So let's cut it some slack. I should see what she does to you, too. Yeah, exactly. ML doesn't always win, but it can help. It does have the ability to, even if you don't have to make a synonym for Jerry and Elaine should match Seinfeld. You can just have this Jerry and Elaine query surface Seinfeld. Just like in our early testing of our feature using open source models, like the thing about today,
而它在进行无保护左转时遇到了困难。所以我们还是对它宽容一点吧。你应该看看她对你做什么。对，没错。机器学习并不总是能赢，但它能提供帮助。它确实有这种能力，即使你不需要为“杰瑞和伊莱恩应该匹配宋飞传”创建一个同义词。你也可以只让这个“杰瑞和伊莱恩”的查询浮现出《宋飞传》。就像在我们使用开源模型对该功能进行的早期测试中，关于今天的事情，
the reason why we're releasing this feature now as opposed to two years ago is I personally felt that the quality, the robustness of the publicly available language models and search engines had reached a point where we could reliably let customers play with and experience the power of what's called semantic search and not have to have like PhDs in data science or statistics or information science to really benefit from these techniques. Like there's a ton of models out there from a variety of companies. And we strongly believe that the open source search engine that powers most people's search applications that are using search engines, because a lot of people are still using databases for crying out loud. Most people that use search engines to power their search applications, we felt like Lucene had come a long way.
我们之所以现在而不是在两年前发布这个功能，是因为我个人觉得，公开可获得的语言模型和搜索引擎的质量与鲁棒性已经达到这样一个地步：我们可以放心地让客户试用并体验所谓的语义搜索的威力，而无需拥有数据科学、统计学或信息科学的博士学位，就能真正从这些技术中受益。正如市面上有很多来自不同公司的模型一样。我们坚信，为大多数使用搜索引擎的用户的搜索应用提供动力的开源搜索引擎——因为很多人还在大喊大叫地使用数据库。大多数使用搜索引擎来为他们的搜索应用提供动力的人，我们觉得Lucene已经取得了长足的进步。
And we also want to contribute to it more at our company. Well, that was a great setup. So we moved through the arc of search and then you kind of started alluding to we and our company. So tell us a little bit about where you're at, what your guy's product is, and sort of like, you know, give us kind of the elevator bit about where you're at, what your guy's product is,
而且我们也希望在我们公司为它做出更多贡献。好吧，这是一个很好的铺垫。所以我们经历了搜索的发展脉络，然后你开始暗示“我们”和“我们的公司”。所以跟我们聊聊你现在在哪里，你们的产品是什么，以及，你知道的，给我们做一个关于你们在哪里的电梯演讲，你们的产品是什么，
and give us the elevator pitch about what you're trying to do. So I'm at MongoDB. And what I'm trying to do is exploit the flexibility and the cognitive continuity of the MongoDB document model to enable the widest swath of people possible to build advanced search systems. Based on the steps I just described, I wrote this on my blog recently, like the cognitive steeplechase of working with a relational database and the throws of tables and rows. It's like, so he's telling me I call an API, that API gives me JSON objects. Then in my programming language, largely object oriented paradigm, I'm building business logic around these objects and manipulating these objects. And then when I go to store it, I have to like effectively use a bunch
并给我们做一个关于你们正试图做的事情的电梯演讲。我在MongoDB。而我正在做的事情是利用MongoDB文档模型的灵活性和认知连续性，让尽可能广泛的人群能够构建先进的搜索系统。基于我刚刚描述的步骤，我最近在我的博客上写过，就像使用关系型数据库的认知障碍（cognitive steeplechase），陷在表和行的泥潭中。就像，所以他告诉我我调用了一个API，那个API给了我JSON对象。然后在我所使用的编程语言（主要是面向对象范式）中，我围绕这些对象构建业务逻辑并操作这些对象。然后当我准备去存储它时，我必须有效地使用一堆
of spreadsheets or file cabinets. Like that's how tables and rows feel to me. Like, you know, my company, like I made all the use in the world of of Postgres and stuff. It was like the cognitive dissonance, like when you're a smaller company and you need to be as efficient as possible and move as fast as possible. Like or even like a personal project or like starting a new thing, like the cognitive continuity pays like serious dividends because I get frustrated less. It's like imagine you're writing some code. You know, you've got your noise canceling headphones on signaling to the world. Leave me alone. Not a very good signal, but yes, I know your intent.
电子表格或文件柜。这就是表和行带给我的感觉。就像，你知道的，我的公司，我充分利用了Postgres之类的一切。那种认知失调，当你是一家小型公司，需要尽可能高效并以最快速度前进时。或者甚至像一个个人项目，或者开始一个新项目时，认知连续性会带来巨大的回报，因为我的挫败感会减少。就像想象你在写一些代码。你知道，你戴着降噪耳机，向世界发出信号：请别打扰我。这不是一个很好的信号，但是的，我明白你的意图。
Yeah. Like, please don't bother me and so you you are in the middle of a function that you're describing and or like you know articulating expressing you're like 70 of the way through if somebody taps you on the shoulder pulls you out of the conference out of the conversation you're having with your ide for or text editor for two minutes, you might have lost the next 15, 30 minutes. You're going to come back and be like, where was I? What line was I on? Where's my cursor? Is Vim in insert mode or not? I don't know what to do. I cannot touch the keyboard back away from the keyboard. Woosa, woosa. I mean, this is a real thing. This is a real thing.
是的。就像，请不要打扰我，然后你正处于你正在描述的某个函数的中间，或者说你正在阐述、表达，你已经完成了70%，如果有人拍拍你的肩膀，把你从你的IDE或文本编辑器带离两分钟，让你中断了与你正在进行的对话，你可能会失去接下来的15分钟、30分钟。等你回来时会想：我刚才写到哪了？我刚才在哪一行？我的光标在哪里？Vim是在插入模式还是别的什么？我不知道该怎么做了。我不能碰键盘，远离键盘。呼，吸，呼，吸。我的意思是，这是真事。这是真事。
And so imagine nobody bothers you. You just went from the API to the business logic and this object-oriented paradigm to the tables and rows. It's the same thing. It's like tables and rows. I was just thinking about these objects. Boom, boom. I'm surprised. And so as a part of your workflow, every 15 minutes, you lose another 15 minutes. It's crazy to me that the discontinuity between the storage layer
所以想象一下没有人打扰你。你刚刚从API、这个面向对象的范式，过渡到了表和行。这完全是一回事。就像表和行一样。我刚才还在想着这些对象。轰，轰。我很惊讶。因此作为你工作流的一部分，每隔15分钟，你就又失去了15分钟。在我看来，存储层与
and the logic layer or like the external system, the access layer, the data layer, if you will, like the discontinuity between the storage layer and most systems. So that's why I was like, okay, MongoDB, I need to go, I need to return there. I built a startup on that continuity. I know how much faster I was able to adapt and innovate and change and mutate and really push out features because I was kind of on the same wavelength. Like nobody was interrupting me. I wasn't interrupting myself.
逻辑层之间的不连续性，或者说外部系统、访问层、数据层（如果你愿意这么叫的话），存储层与大多数系统之间的不连续性实在是太疯狂了。这就是为什么我想，好吧，MongoDB，我需要回去，我需要回到那里。我曾在那种连续性之上建立了一家初创公司。我知道自己能够以多快的速度去适应、创新、改变、变异并真正推出功能，因为我和它处于同一波段。没有人打扰我。我自己也没有打扰我自己。
And so I was like, if I really want to get this out, if my dream is really to get the power of high-dimensional vector space to the world for a variety of applications. It's not just a search box. Remember, search engines are the technology underlying so many different technologies, whether it's like fraud prevention, personalization, recommendations, or like drug discovery, gene profiling and descriptions, like predicting interactions. Like this could be life-changing stuff. And so the way I'm going to get this to the world is the path of least resistance, which I certainly see as the document model that's been pioneered by MongoDB. At this point, they're not the only ones because people have like wisened up. They understand now, but they're certainly, they built the most robust business
所以我想，如果我真的想把这个推向世界，如果我的梦想真的是将高维向量空间的威力带给各种应用的全世界。这不仅仅是一个搜索框。记住，搜索引擎是众多不同技术背后的底层技术，无论是防欺诈、个性化、推荐，还是药物发现、基因分析和描述、预测相互作用。这可能是能改变生命的东西。因此，我将这个带给世界的方式就是阻力最小的路径，我坚信这就是由MongoDB开创的文档模型。在这一点上，他们不是唯一的一家，因为人们已经变聪明了。他们现在明白了，但他们确实是，他们围绕这个价值主张建立了最强大的业务，
around this value prop and certainly the most robust managed service, which I think is just like, it has to be managed because that's another thing. It's like, okay, if I get the document stuff figured out, if I have to go think about racking and stacking servers. I feel like I'm in 2008 and AWS isn't a thing. It's like, come on. There are these managed services. You should use them. Engineering is, for me, a quest to simplify. Constantly iterate to further simplify. And MongoDB really let me do that i left i was in grad school at the university of michigan uh and the information the school of information and like i learned a lot of things really quickly and i didn't stay for very long because it was super complex for like it wasn't like i understood what was going on,
当然也是最强大的托管服务，我认为这绝对是必须的，因为这是另一回事。好吧，如果我把文档的事情搞定了，如果我还得去考虑机架和服务器堆叠。我觉得自己好像回到了2008年，当时AWS还不存在。拜托。现在有这些托管服务。你应该使用它们。对我来说，工程学是一场追求简化的征程。不断迭代以实现进一步简化。而MongoDB真正让我做到了这一点。我离开时，我曾是密歇根大学的研究生，在信息学院，我非常快地学到了很多东西，但我并没有呆太久，因为对……来说它超级复杂，并不是说我不懂发生了什么，
but it was like, I need to go to the world and tell them you don't need to do this. Like I want some people to go to grad school. It was like, but you can, like with MongoDB, if you're in high school, you can get started. Like there is a free tier and Atlas is free forever. If you're, you're mid career, you're 40, you want to keep your skills sharp, you can go get started. You can load a sample data set for free in a managed service nearby your house. There's like 90 something regions supported all over the world. You can get started and you can
而是我觉得我需要走向世界，告诉他们你们不需要这么做。就像我希望有些人去读研究生一样。但这就像，通过MongoDB，如果你是个高中生，你就可以开始上手。有一个免费层，而且Atlas永远免费。如果你是职业中期，你40岁了，想保持你的技能敏锐，你也可以开始上手。你可以在你家附近的托管服务中免费加载一个示例数据集。全世界支持的大约有90多个区域。你可以开始上手，并且你可以
create a search index with a click of a button or one API call. And then that's really powerful to me. At the end, I'll say all set, you're, or you're all set. And then you get a little button. You can just click it, type into the search box, view the query syntax, and you're off to the races. And so if we get all of that out the way and make that part simple for you, then you can understand or even start down the path of, hey, I want to run every query that comes in, every text query that my users provide. I want to transform that into a dense vector and submit that to MongoDB as a vector input and then calculate some similarity, whether it be Euclidean distance or dot product or cosine similarity of that query vector to my corpus of vectors to surface documents I didn't even know were in this corpus
只需点击一个按钮或进行一次API调用，就能创建一个搜索索引。这对我来说非常强大。最后，我会说一切就绪，你，或者说一切都准备好了。然后你会得到一个小按钮。你只需点击它，在搜索框中输入内容，查看查询语法，然后你就可以全速起步了。所以，如果我们把所有这些都抛开，把这部分对你来说变得简单，那么你就可以理解或者甚至开始走上这样一条道路：嘿，我想运行进来的每一个查询，我的用户提供的每一个文本查询。我想把它转换成一个稠密向量，并将其作为向量输入提交给MongoDB，然后计算某种相似性，无论是欧几里得距离、点积还是余弦相似度，将那个查询向量与我的向量语料库进行比较，从而浮现出我甚至不知道在这个语料库中存在的文档，
or relationships I wasn't even aware of. That's super powerful to me. And then you talk about audio, video, like next we're going to be ideas if we ever get this Neuralink thing. So you're doing my job for me. I was just going to ask. All right. But it sounds like, okay, so Atlas is the managed instance, managed service for MongoDB. Is that right? Yeah, that's right. Okay, cool. So if people are listening and they want to try, it sounds like, I mean, you already did that. I'm just repeating it. But like, you know, they can go sign up on the website, they can put some example, like data in there, they can start searching, they can really kind of experience that. I think that's an awesome opportunity. I think people listening who this is not your field today, I mean, or even if it is, and you're interested, doing that firsthand experience is like one of the best ways to learn one of the best ways to immerse yourself. And I think as Marcus was describing, hit your head on the really obvious problems first before setting out to like, solve the hardest problem, and really kind of advance the understanding and learn what you need to layer on next. I think that was a wise words, wise words. Just great points. Thank you. The next question is like, what about working at
或者我甚至没有意识到过的关系。这对我来说超级强大。然后你谈到音频、视频，接下来如果我们要搞这个Neuralink脑机接口的东西，那就会是各种想法。所以你是在帮我代劳。我正要问呢。好吧。但听起来，好吧，所以Atlas是MongoDB的托管实例、托管服务。是这样吗？是的，没错。好的，太酷了。所以如果人们在听，并且想尝试一下，听起来——我的意思是，你已经说过了。我只是在重复。但就像，你知道的，他们可以去网站注册，他们可以在里面放一些示例数据，他们可以开始搜索，他们真的可以去体验一下。我认为这是一个极好的机会。我认为正在收听的、目前还不是这个领域的人（我的意思是，即使你是，并且你对此感兴趣），亲自动手去体验是最好的学习方法之一，也是让自己沉浸其中的最好方法之一。而且正如马库斯（Marcus）所描述的那样，在着手解决最困难的问题之前，先在那些非常明显的问题上碰壁，并真正开始提升理解力，学习接下来你需要叠加什么。我认为这是明智之言，明智之言。观点真是太棒了。谢谢。下一个问题是，在MongoDB工作是怎样的体验？
MongoDB? How is working at MongoDB? Like, are you guys hiring? Do you do internships? Where could people look? What's the kind of culture like? Just kind of give us the feel about a life there. So we're permanently hiring. If that gives you any insight into how much work there is to do. We're powering mission-critical infrastructure for a lot of the world. The whole world runs on MongoDB, seriously. And so, so many applications you would never even think of. There used to be this joke, oh, MongoDB is web scale. No, it's not.
在MongoDB工作感觉如何？你们在招人吗？你们有实习吗？人们可以去哪里查看？这里的文化是怎样的？给我们一种在那里的生活感受吧。我们一直在招聘。如果这能让你对这里有多少工作要做有一点了解的话。我们正在为世界上许多地方提供关键任务基础设施。整个世界都运行在MongoDB上，说真的。因此，有那么多你甚至从未想过的应用程序。过去有个笑话，哦，MongoDB具备网络规模。不，它不具备。
It's like, whatever. Yes, it is. I mean, whatever you define it as, there's a lot of people using MongoDB at super high volumes. And so what that means as we move to support more of the demanding customers in the world, many of them, I think something like four out of five financial transactions, something crazy like that. But like like all these really large use cases means we need a lot of help. And then we're also very focused on the developer. And so we don't go as fast as some of these companies. Like you'll hear people talk about, as I get into the culture here, you'll
随便吧。是的，它具备。无论你怎么定义它，都有很多人在极高的吞吐量下使用MongoDB。这意味着，随着我们努力支持世界上更多要求苛刻的客户，他们中的许多人，我想大约五分之四的金融交易，类似这样疯狂的数字。但是所有这些非常大的用例意味着我们需要大量的帮助。然后我们也非注重开发者。所以我们不像其中一些公司那样发展得那么快。就像你会听到人们在谈论——当我进入这里的文化时，你会
hear people talk about, you know, we ship to production, you know, 12 times a week on average. That's not how we operate because like we're focused on your experience. Like how does it feel to work with this database? If we ever start to break that cognitive continuity that I think is, is our biggest advantage and worth so much more than people have realized, then I think it becomes less of an interesting place for me. Like, because right now it is the simplest way, you know, to make use of your data, to get to a place where you can innovate fast and really start to explore and push the boundaries and iterate in a lot of features. So you can rest assured we're not moving super fast in that way. But relative, I mean, relative to the other database companies or infrastructure companies,
听到人们说，你知道的，我们平均每周向生产环境发布12次。我们不是这样运作的，因为我们专注于你的体验。就像与这个数据库合作感觉如何？如果我们开始打破我认为了不起的、并且比人们意识到的更有价值的这种认知连续性，那么我认为这里对我就变得不再那么有趣了。因为现在它是利用你的数据的最简单方式，能让你达到能够快速创新、真正开始探索、突破界限并在许多功能上进行迭代的境界。所以你可以放心，我们在那种方式上并不会走得超级快。但相对而言，我的意思是，相对于其他数据库公司或基础设施公司，
we move pretty fast. And maybe it's because we don't, we have that continuity, right? Ourselves, we work with the database all the time, so we can move faster we have like just tremendous uh set of internal tools and applications powered by mongodb and that is i mean that's one of our competitive advantages it's like we have the our people working on these systems have the cognitive continuity it's a some teams lean sort of academic in nature. Some teams are newer and maybe play a little more fast and loose. Doing a lot of experiments, like really trying to figure out what's the right direction, what's the right thing. There's a mixture of roles ranging from like we have an education engineering team, which like builds like MongoDB University, which is a free portal where you can
我们行动相当快。也许是因为我们没有，我们拥有那种连续性，对吧？我们自己一直都在与数据库打交道，所以我们可以行动得更快。我们拥有极其庞大的由MongoDB驱动的内部工具和应用程序集，我的意思是，那是我们的竞争优势之一。我们的员工在这些系统上工作时拥有认知连续性。有些团队本质上偏向学术风格。有些团队比较新，也许行事更灵活随意一些。做很多实验，真正试图弄清楚正确的方向是什么，正确的事情是什么。这里有各种各样的角色，从我们有一个教育工程团队（它构建了MongoDB University，这是一个免费的门户网站，如果你在学校里还没有学到它，你可以去那里学习MongoDB，我认为每个人都应该去，因为它是免费的。或者如果你在工作中没有学到它，绝对要去MongoDB University。它太棒了。对我的帮助极大），
go and learn MongoDB if you're not being taught it in school yet, which I think everyone should do it because it's free. Or if you're not being taught it on the job, definitely go to MongoDB University. It's awesome. Helped me tremendously. And then we have Docs Platform. We maintain our own Docs Platform. And then we have the managed service in the database and the search system and the mobile database and the serverless functions and like charts and like some of these things go very very very in the weeds you know like uh but you can rest assured coming to a place like mago d you're surrounded by world class minds, world class talent. Like the predominant storage engine and Oracle today was architected by Michael Call and Keith Bostic, who they wrote it. It's called Sleepy Cat. And this is like in the early 90s or something oracle bought sleepy cat then they built in the
然后我们还有文档平台（Docs Platform）。我们维护自己的文档平台。然后我们还有托管服务、数据库、搜索系统、移动数据库、无服务器函数以及图表（Charts），其中有些东西非常非常深入细节，你知道的，不过你可以放心，来到像MongoDB这样的地方，你身边都是世界一流的头脑、世界一流的天才。今天甲骨文（Oracle）的主要存储引擎是由迈克尔·卡尔（Michael Call）和基思·博斯克（Keith Bostic）架构的，他们编写了它。它叫做Sleepy Cat。这大概是在90年代初什么的，甲骨文收购了Sleepy Cat，然后在2000年代十几岁的时候，我相信迈克尔·卡尔和基思·博斯克重新聚在一起，创办了一家新公司，他们构建了WiredTiger这个新存储引擎，而MongoDB收购了WiredTiger公司。基思·博斯克最近退休了，他告诉我，甲骨文并不想要这个设计。这就像，你喜欢哪个存储引擎？你更喜欢Sleepy Cat还是WiredTiger？这听起来像是一个伟大而完美的闭环。所以你们真的是方方面面都覆盖到了。对。是的。我的意思是，MongoDB就是数据存储、访问和信息检索的下一代。
2000 teens i believe michael call and keith bostick came back together started a new company and they built wire tiger a new storage engine and mongo db acquired the wire tiger company i keep bostick who recently retired told me that Oracle didn't want the design. It's so like which which storage engine do you like? Would you prefer Sleepy Cat or Wired Tiger? It sounds like this great this great full circle. So you're really covering all the bases. Yeah. Yeah. I mean, like we're going to be like MongoDB is the next generation of data storage and access information retrieval.
因此，我认为你来到MongoDB就是为了与尖端专家在一起，与成长最快的公司以及活着的成长最快的数据库公司一起工作。每个人都非常好。他们非常努力地为各种各样的人腾出空间。就像有几个人，包括我自己，可能会被认为有点古怪，但没关系。我整天都在思考——我的意思是，我的大脑此时此刻就是一个倒排索引。所以有时我会浮现出你本不打算浮现的文档。而在其他时候，
And so, like, I think that you come to MongoDB to be with the experts on the cutting edge, work with the fastest growing companies and the fastest growing database company alive. Everyone is really nice. They work really hard to make space for all kinds of people. Like there are several people, including myself, who might be characterized as a little weird, but it's fine. I spent all my day thinking like, I mean, my brain is an inverted index at this point. And so sometimes I surface documents that you didn't intend to service. And like other times,
这正是你在寻找的。你必须调对频道。然后，你知道的，我们在我们的总部纽约市有工程师。都柏林是我们的欧洲总部。都柏林以及——我的意思是，巴塞罗那和柏林都是不断发展的工程办公室，都有空缺职位。我们还有现场工程师（field engineers）。
it's exactly what you're looking for. You kind of have to be tuned. And then, you know, we have engineers in New York City, our headquarters. Dublin is our EU headquarters. Dublin and, I mean, Barcelona and Berlin are both growing engineering offices with openings. And we have field engineers.
这正是你在寻找的。你得调整到那个频率。然后，你知道的，我们在纽约市有工程师，那是我们的总部。都柏林是我们的欧盟总部。都柏林，我的意思是，巴塞罗那和柏林都是不断发展的工程办公室，并且有职位空缺。我们还有现场工程师。
You can come here if you want to write just a little bit of code or a certain subset of code and work as a support engineer or consulting engineer or solutions architect. If you don't feel you want to be only coding, right, with the software engineering organization. We also have a large team in India, I believe in Singapore, we have a pretty big engineering team and Australia, and also San Francisco and Austin, pretty and we have like, field teams all over the world. You know, we follow the sun there. And so it's a it's a it's a pretty exciting place to be. It's very diverse. I think we're getting better and pretty much every category of diversity. And we don't just think about like what someone looks like. It's also like, what's their perspective?
如果你想编写少量的代码或者特定子集的代码，并担任支持工程师、咨询工程师或解决方案架构师，你可以来到这里。如果你觉得自己不想仅仅局限于软件工程组织的纯编码工作。我们在印度也有一支庞大的团队，我相信在新加坡、澳大利亚、旧金山和奥斯汀也都有相当规模的工程团队，我们在世界各地都有现场团队。你知道，我们在那里实行日不落的工作模式。所以这是一个非常激动人心的地方。它非常多元化。我认为我们在几乎所有维度的多元化上都在变得更好。而且我们不仅仅考虑一个人的外表，还要考虑他们的视角。
Well, that was great, Marcus. And, you know, I think this has been super helpful to me. I mean, I learned a lot through the podcast today. This idea you said, it wasn't even like the topic of search, but this like cognitive continuity. People who work with me hear me talk about like cognitive burden. It's like kind of, I feel like very similar concepts, like really helping people make sure that when they're engaged in the flow, that this is something worth optimizing for, that making sure that whatever you're doing users, people writing code,
好的，马库斯，太棒了。而且，你知道，我觉得这对我也非常有帮助。我的意思是，我通过今天的播客学到了很多。你提到的这个观点，甚至都不是关于搜索的主题，而是关于这种认知连续性。与我共事的人经常听到我谈论类似“认知负担”的概念。我觉得这与你的观点非常相似，真的在帮助人们确保当他们处于心流状态时，这是值得优化的一件事情，确保无论你在做什么用户、编写代码的人，
like making sure that you, you sort of reduce the amount of simultaneous complex concepts that have to be held in your head. And I I'm with you there. And I, I think this has been like really awesome. I know the listeners are going to really enjoy hearing this tour de force really of, of search.
都要确保你减少了脑海中必须同时容纳的复杂概念的数量。我完全赞同你的看法。而且我认为这真的非常棒。我知道听众们一定会非常喜欢听这场关于搜索的精彩绝伦的讨论。
You covered, I don't know, probably a thousand Googleable terms and, you know, years of study probably to get to the bottom of all of it. So I really appreciate you coming on and I really thank you for taking time. Thanks, Patrick. I really appreciate it. Thanks, Jason. Really appreciate it. Yeah. Thanks so much. It was, this is absolutely amazing. I mean, there's a, there's a ton of terms here. I think we, we, you know,
你涵盖了，我不知道，可能上千个可以通过谷歌搜索到的术语，你知道，可能需要多年的研究才能完全搞懂所有这些。所以我非常感谢你能来，也非常感谢你抽出时间。谢谢你，帕特里克。我真的很感激。谢谢你，杰森。真的非常感激。是的，非常感谢。这绝对太棒了。我的意思是，这里有大量的术语。我想我们，你知道，
covered a whirlwind of things. So folks, if you have questions, we'll post Twitter handles. You can add us. You can add Marcus and ask questions and get engaged. It's a really interesting topic. Super, super important. Yeah, if you want early access, I'll have to plug it again. To semantic search capabilities, we're collecting again to semantic search capabilities. We're collecting, you know, people to get early access to those capabilities, because, like I said, we really want you to ensure that you're set up for success and that and you're not confused and that you can use it in a way that's cost effective and allows you to really benefit from the technology.
涵盖了旋风般丰富的内容。所以各位，如果您有疑问，我们会发布推特账号。您可以添加我们。您可以添加马库斯并提出问题进行互动。这是一个非常有趣的话题。超级、超级重要。是的，如果您想要抢先体验，我得再次安利一下语义搜索功能，我们正在再次收集语义搜索功能的用户。我们在收集想要抢先体验这些功能的人，因为就像我说的，我们真的希望确保您获得成功，不会感到困惑，并且能够以经济高效的方式使用它，让您真正受益于这项技术。
Well, thank you, everyone. We'll see you next time. Music by Eric Barndollar Programming Throwdown is distributed under a Creative Commons Attribution Sharealike 2.0 license. You're free to share, copy, distribute, transmit the work, to remix, adapt the work, but you must provide attribution to Patrick and I and sharealike in time. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
好的，谢谢大家。我们下次再见。音乐由 Eric Barndollar 提供。《Programming Throwdown》基于知识共享署名-相同方式共享 2.0 协议发布。您可以自由分享、复制、分发、传输作品，也可以进行混音和改编，但您必须署名我和帕特里克，并采用相同的授权方式。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。